your character in ER played a pivotal
role in a major storyline did you know
going in to what impact Paul was going
to have well yeah I mean I I you know I
kill the character off the show and stab
the out of the main the lead
character of the show um but uh I didn't
expect you know it's crazy because shows
you know TV shows don't get that kind of
viewership anymore I mean they were
getting like 25 million people a week
watching that show so what I was
surprised if anything surprised me was
like the day after or the week after
where like I'd be walking down the
street in LA and or going to some
restaurant in La and and people be like
you scared the out of us or
whatever and I'm Wella you saw that it's
like wow a lot of people you really go
like well man TV is far reaching man
like super far reaching